my next guest has shown off his singing
voice on both stage and screen
he is an actor producer author singer
and the rare quintuple threat
also a magician the fourth and final
book in his children series the magic
misfits is out now
please welcome neil patrick harris y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
oh oh my gosh get in your nose
[Laughter]
hi kelly what an entrance i love hey
thanks
i got to be honest with you i'm 38 years
old and i still get a kick out of a
magnifying glass
doesn't exactly stop trying bugs though
when i
when i was much oh my gosh i used to do
that with paper not you know
living things but yeah i would burn
holes in paper um but it's been a few
a few years since we've seen each other
right it has been a few years i can't
see you at
all i see a big giant screen that says i
look
hot
you're welcome you living in your pink
greatness with someone else's hair neil
but it's fine
um i almost wore that
you'd probably look better you jerk um
so wait i actually just celebrated 18
years
since idol and it made me think of you
because i remember you telling me
because somebody was talking about a
moment like this um that people use it
for weddings a lot
and i was like i remember neil telling
me that did was that y'all's dance
was that the song that you was our first
dance song that was our song kelly
clarkson
we don't have many people in our lives
that we talk like 13 year old school
girls about
and it's it's you are one of them and
and you're that song we met during i
think season
two of american idol when and it was
still this giant juggernaut and i think
that your song that song was
was playing a lot and was still
connected with and so
we were falling in love at that same
time and the lyrics to that song always
kind of stayed with us
and we always said you know if we ever
got married that would be a great
first dance song especially with two
guys
people wait a lifetime for a moment like
this some people search forever for that
one special kiss it was so
it was so perfect and our parents were
there and we got to dance with them
i love your smile you're like reliving
it
but anyway i i also know you're really
into halloween i am as well and it's
coming up so are you guys
trick-or-treating this year like
we don't really know what protocol is i
think i'm going to throw a dance party
at my house
with my kids and me yeah i'm not sure
either i love halloween like i love
christmas
um maybe more so in certain ways because
i don't have to buy a bunch of gifts
but maybe less so in certain ways
because they don't get a bunch of gifts
although candy counts
so i don't know we usually do a family
picture and we may still figure that out
although our resources are limited to
staying here
we're not in the city we normally live
in new york city and we're sort of we
have a little farmhouse that we
that we just finished and we moved into
so we're here which is a bit more
suburban a bit more normal which is
great
at the same time i'm not sure i think
because of the situation we'll probably
encourage everyone like our kids and us
to
go trick-or-treating if we can wearing
masks like like finding a costume that
was
mask specific uh and then hope that
there's protocols in place so that
we can still social distance i just miss
i love the
i love the quintessential walking down
the sidewalk
seeing the house should we go into this
house and walking up and knocking on the
door and yeah waiting for someone to
open the door so i hope that some of
that can happen it's not just buckets of
candy
like thrown on the street and you just
have to kind of fend for yourselves
a card though right you said the photo
but don't y'all do a card every year
um we sort of release a picture like a a
instagrammy picture of us in
some sort of fun costume so we did it
really really when the kids were
much younger and then we just keep doing
them every year it's fun for me to
to do a little photo shopping here and
there and that was yeah the haunted
mansion at disney how can you not do
that one year
um so we have an idea but it's not going
to be quite as outlandish i don't think
as
in years past but i do like to keep the
spirit of halloween alive anyway i'm
able
oh i think it's so fun i'm like not even
about a party unless it has a theme so
obviously i love halloween
this is such a great book so so this is
the final book in your children's series
right
i was asked to write a middle grade
fiction book and i said i'd do it if i
could write four of them and i wanted to
write about magic and i wanted to write
about kids because i have two of them
and i love the
former and so i wanted to write
something that had to do with real magic
because i love magic
cards and coins and and illusion not um
not potter magic and wands and
wizards and things like that and so
that's what i did and each book
chronicles one of these four kids that
lives in a fictional town called mineral
wells
and each book is through the perspective
of one of those kids and so we're at the
fourth book it's a girl named
ridley larson she's a wheelchair-bound
awesome amazing chick who
is all about transformation turning one
thing into another thing you see the
book even looks like a
playing card all four look like that so
she's uh she's super amazing
dealing with her mom dealing with her
stresses and figuring out who the the
evil guy is in this this
awful magic group called the emerald
ring who's disbanded them who's burned
the magic shop down
and this is the final story where it all
kind of comes together and
we learn we learn all the things we need
to know the book has
teaches magic tricks within it so if you
want to learn some magic tricks each
book has four or five different teacher
tricks throughout
there's codes there's puzzles there's
ciphers so i really respect readers
respect
kids and um i'm so stoked the books have
done well and i hope this one continues
the trend
yeah no it's obviously done well and how
innovative that's so cool to make them
like a part of the story they get to
learn stuff from the book and like kind
of be part of it that's really cool
definitely definitely yeah you like
magic right i love
magic and i actually heard like i am
like i'm a child when people do magic in
front of me it's annoying
um but you also created a magical board
game i heard is that real
that is real as well i i
i love buying the games but i always
find that they're party
games you know that they're do you have
it there can i see it do you have it
it's like
four to 12 players and so i said why not
make a
party game for just one person it's
called box one it's created just by me
and it's only uh one person it's not
something you play with your spouse it's
not something you play with a group of
people
if you like the codes and the puzzles
and in sort of escape room adjacent
um i love tape rooms i i definitely
suggest this for you i love escape rooms
dude i can't get enough of them and it's
one of the things that i
am so bummed about all this pandemic
nonsense is that you can't go to escape
rooms
oh my gosh i am obsessed with them
it's so clever it's such a clever thing
okay at some point when we're allowed to
be around humans again and they start
that up we need to do an escape room
together
i would love to in the meantime i
recommend box one but only when you're
by yourself
okay i love that because i don't often
have people to play games with sometimes
so
[Music]